in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I help some educators with their
TCP window sizes well their networking
performance make the grade stay tuned to
find out to dorama is a platform which
provides crowdsource instructional
videos to help teach people how to do
everything from properly walking a dog
to filing their taxes in order to handle
a massive spike in video content they
recently upgraded their connection
between their on-prem setup and Google
cloud platform but despite their fancy
new connection their performance didn't
seem to improve in the way they expected
running I perfect between their local
servers and a GCP instance was only
getting about 1.1 megabits a second now
we've already seen that this is way
below what GCP can support in terms of
transfer speeds so well we went down the
list checking their core count if they
were using the right IP and what regions
they were optimizing for and by the way
if you want to run those same tests
check out the videos linked in the
description sadly none of these things
had an impact on their performance as
such I took this problem to a few of our
networking gurus and after some thought
and debate they all pointed me in the
same direction to something called
bandwidth delay products see TCP
protocol uses specific window sizes that
define how much data to send between
endpoints before needing and
acknowledgment when your endpoints are
physically close to each other this
information can be sent acknowledged
quickly but as that distance increases
so does the time it takes for the
destination to acknowledge a window of
data since we end up getting capped by
physics but here's the important part
any time an endpoint is forced to wait
for an acknowledgment of a packet it
creates gaps in the data flow which then
limits the performance of the connection
as such it's really important to
fine-tune the TCP window sizes of a
connection so that either side doesn't
end up waiting for these situations now
to be fair most modern OSS do a good job
of Auto tuning the TCP buffer sizes but
in some cases the default values are
still too small and as it turns out be
too dorama networking engineers had
already adjusted these windows based on
their previous connection speeds so to
figure out how the new set up was
performing by default we set up a test
from their system without any adjusted
windows and saw a whopping
90 megabits per second for external IP
access from there we used a few online
calculators to try to find better values
for the TCP windows but quite frankly
the defaults for the GCP instances
produce the best results for the tutor
AMA team at this point the only advice I
could give them was don't touch the
defaults now I don't say that very often
but a 90 X improvement is really hard to
beat if you'd like more details on this
problem check out the full article in
the description below and make sure to
subscribe to our Google cloud YouTube
channel to get alerts when new
performance videos come out and don't
forget when it comes to performance
every millisecond counts